When I go down deep basements, the ones I already
know, well, I love it because they
are always new experiences, it is always
different when you discover new things,
because it is like opening doors to the
unknown, and for me that is something that
fills me with satisfaction
[Music]
My name is Carlos Edmundo  corte zorrilla i
am a speleologist, rescuer and river guide
i have been exploring caves for the last
10 years
here in the state of san luís potosí
where i live we have around 480
virgin explored caves many
more been around
230 different caves
all the cellars are different te
you find many different things here
in the basement of the buses where
we are right now the swifts live the
basement of the brush is not completely
rocky with a cenote below because
the light does not enter other than the rays that
filter that there is little light
So there is not so much animal
or vegetable vegetation, they
are some of the most beautiful basements in the
world that I have seen.  ted because it
has information it seems that you are in
a cathedral inside the places this
what is impressive is the
opening of the hole
at the beginning when you connect to the
rope no matter how much experience you already
have in making such deep descents
if you feel the adrenaline
when  you are going to get hung up on the system
to start descending it
is an activity that you cannot do
alone
I always bring at least 6 people because
something can happen it
is part of my daily therapy being in
contact with nature
with the caves discovering places that
practically no one has been  Well, I've been
involved in this for quite a few years,
devoting myself completely to what I do,
I like it a lot
[Music]